seit tagen geht hier in deutschland
eigentlich der lockdown aber die korona
zahlen die bleiben weiter hoch wie passt
das zusammen
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit
professor christian hesse von der uni
stuttgart guten abend sie sind statistik
profi der zahlen erklären sie uns einmal
wie passt das alles zusammen warum gehen
diese zahlen nicht endlich runter ja
schon guten abend auch ein harter
lockdown hat eigentlichen bremsweg bevor
er wirkt ein guter indikator dafür ist
der hatte locker und den wir ja schon im
märz hatten und modellrechnungen
aufgrund der damals gemachten
erfahrungen zeigen dass das etwa zehn
tage dauert vom beginn slaughter bis die
wichtigen kennzahlen wie etwa die
täglichen neuinfizierten und die sieben
tage instanzen nicht mehr zu nehmen
sondern beginnen abzuklingen das wäre
dann bei uns etwa ab dem 26
dezember zu erwarten jetzt ist aber
genau davor natürlich weihnachten und
auch wenn diesmal alle dazu aufgerufen
sind in möglichst kleinen kreis zu
feiern natürlich trifft man seine
familie welche auswirkungen wird
weihnachten werden die feiertage also
wahrscheinlich jetzt noch einmal auf
unsere zahlen haben
es hängt natürlich teilweise davon ab
wie sich die mehrheit der bevölkerung
weihnachten verhalten wird es ist aber
dennoch zu befürchten dass aufgrund der
leichten lockerungen die es weihnacht
mehr geben soll und einfach aufgrund der
zig millionen persönlichen kontakten in
innenräumen möglicherweise weihnachten
dennoch zu einem global super
präsentiert sich selbst in jeder ihrer
einzelner kontakt mit einem infizierten
der ist aber dennoch symptome spürt nur
mit geringer wahrscheinlichkeit zu einer
ansteckung führt ist allein aufgrund des
gesetzes der großen zahlen der großen
zahl der kontakte mit einer erheblichen
zahl von neuinfektionen zu rechnen jetzt
haben wir auch schon mit karl lauterbach
darüber gesprochen wie lange dieser
lockdown jetzt wahrscheinlich noch an
wann wird denn man kann ja sagen der
zehnte januar den nimmt keiner mehr
wirklich für den richtigen endpunkt
dieses lockte herr lauterbach hatte
jetzt gesagt wenn die inzidenz bei 25
liegt das klingt so als wäre das noch
eine ganz ganz lange zeit hin in ihrer
einschätzung wie lange muss dieser
locker wie lange wird dieser lockt dann
in deutschland noch nötig sein
modellrechnungen zeigen dass vom beginn
des doktor angerechnet etwa drei wochen
vergehen bis die instanzen sich halbiert
haben und dann weitere zwei wochen bis
sich abermals halbiert haben also auf
ein vierter
und dann sind wir etwa beim 20 januar
und wir werden bei einer bei einem wert
von etwa 50 pence wert von etwa 50 und
dabei ist schon vorausgesetzt dass
weihnachten nichts passiert was die
zahlen wieder in die höhen trat also
dieser zehnte januar ist auf jeden fall
praktisch unmöglich es ist
höchstwahrscheinlich so dass am 10
januar die die wirkung des doktors noch
nicht so stark ist dass man ihn auch
reden kann ich persönlich rechne damit
dass der druck da ein bisschen im
februar gehen muss damit die inzidenz
werte und die zahl der neuinfektionen so
weit reduziert wurde
dass die gesundheitsämter die
infektionsketten zurückverfolgen können
und die intensivstationen entlastet
werden herr hesse eine allerletzte frage
wenn sie sagen das wird bis mitte
februar etwa dauern dann denke ich an
den vergangenen februar als sozusagen
corona zu uns kamen dann hat es naja 6 8
wochen gedauert und wir saßen alle zu
hause
droht uns das wiedersehen sie sozusagen
dann eine dritte welle mit einem dritten
lockdown was sagen da die
modellrechnungen
es kommt sehr stark darauf an welches
verhalten die mehrheit der bevölkerung
jetzt über weihnachten tatsächlich eine
tag legen wird
es ist zu befürchten dass durch
weihnachten und durch die zahl der
neuinfizierten die es dann geben wird
eine dritte welle ausgelöst werden kann
dann ist es tatsächlich so dass die
anstellung bei corona auch sehr stark
nach dem zufallsprinzip funktioniert die
das bedeutet dass wenn ich einen kontakt
mit einem infizierten habe so heißt das
nicht dass ich mich dann unweigerlich
auch infiziere sondern es ist
tatsächlich so dass nach neueren studien
dass wir es auch im prinzip soll das
bedeutet dass 20 prozent der infizierten
tatsächlich 80 prozent der ansteckung
verursacher nicht lasst uns dieses 80 20
und 7 dass ich in sehr vielen ursache
wirkungsbeziehungen findet auch im alter
noch 20 prozent der autofahrer
verursachen 80 prozent der unfälle 20
prozent der käufer
sorgen für 80 prozent der umsetzung
möchte dieses 80 20 50 und das zeit
braucht des chors
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren